[Music]
[Music]
he killed marion and he attacked lindsay
too what karen we didn't know for sure i
didn't know what to tell you mom i just
want you to be okay listen i just want
you to know when he gets here i'm gonna
kill him
because 40 years ago when i was a kid
you protected me
so tonight i'm going to protect you
okay
nurse
you know i appreciate you but could you
get out please
like get out now
we had him
how did he escape i don't know
i don't know what do we do we don't have
the police support we fight
we always fight
[Music]
i can't see you shake my hand
[Music]
[Music]
um
my grandmother was right
the boogeyman was real it's over we
can't hurt anyone ever again
no one told you
told me what
somebody in there
[Music]
michael myers
stop you had a knife in your stomach you
and allison
should not have to keep running
evil
dies
tonight
[Music]
i'm not just gonna sit and watch another
innocent person die
if you track michael's victim
it's a straight line to michael's
childhood home
what do we do we fight
let's hunt him down
michael myers is flesh and blood
but a man couldn't have survived that
fire
the more he kills
the more he transcends
he's the essence of evil
[Music]
[Music]
do it
you want your mask
come and get it
i'm coming for you michael
[Music]
you